morning everybody it is seven o'clock
breaking news out of the US this morning
multiple fatalities at a shooting at a
supermarket in Virginia we're hearing
that the shooter has died and several
people have been killed we're live in
the USA shortly uh meantime here in the
UK man United's American owners could be
on the way out we're live at Old
Trafford at a big Court decision this
morning on whether a second Scottish
independence referendum can take place
without westminster's approval also on
the program the work and pension
secretary Mel stride and the leader of
the rmt Union Mick Lynch it's Wednesday
the 23rd of November
Manchester United's American owners
confirmed they could sell the club after
a controversial 17-year reign
Judgment Day the Supreme Court will
decide if a second Scottish independence
referendum can take place without the
approval of Westminster
police in the United States say there
have been multiple fatalities in
shootings at a Walmart store in Virginia
these are the latest pictures reaching
us
here in Qatar concerned for Harry Kane
England captains due to have a scan on
his ankle ahead of England's next match
against the United States on Friday
more rail misery with fresh strikes
planned for the peak Christmas travel
period Speaking to the rmt union leader
Mick Lynch
will the real Liz trust police stand up
who is the real is trust speaking to the
authors of a new book charting the rise
and fall of Britain's shortest serving
prime minister Plus
come fly with me let's fly let's fly
away
[Music]
planning on flying away we'll tell you
which UK airport has the worst security
cues
[Music]
all of that to come but we start with
breaking news on the program this
morning out of the United States police
say several people have died in a
shooting at a Walmart store in Virginia
there have already been 600 mass
shootings in America so far this year
our us correspondent Martha Kellner is
with us um hi Martha what more do we
know good morning
molding K well this is another day
another mass shooting in America this
time it's going to be the city of
Chesapeake in Virginia on America's East
Coast which will wake up tomorrow
morning to learn of the horrific
Bloodshed at a Walmart supermarket we
still don't know the exact number of
fatalities but we do know that there
have been multiple deaths and multiple
injuries inside that Walmart supermarket
that you can see there in the last hour
or so the the local Chesapeake Police
have been giving a press conference that
the spokesman there said that they
received a call around 10 past 10 in the
evening and to tell them of reports of a
shooting at that Supermarket police
officers then entered the store he said
that over the course of 35 to 40 minutes
officers found multiple dead people and
injured people in the store he said they
put rescue and tactical teams together
to go inside and provide life-saving
measures he also said Mr Kaczynski the
the spokesman the officers were still
searching for victims more than two
hours after they arrived on the scene he
noted that it was a large store which
had lots of hiding spots for Shoppers
who had possibly sought cover during the
shooting people could get scared he said
we want to make sure that everyone is
accounted for I think it's important at
this juncture to to reflect on the
astonishing and horrific level of gun
violence in America I'm sure people will
have heard over the weekend of the
shooting or on Saturday night at an
lgbtq nightclub in Colorado Springs in
Colorado five people were killed in that
incident and 17 wounded since then there
have been five more mass shootings mass
shootings defined as incidents where
four or more people are injured or
killed not including the shooter in
addition this is the 607th mass shooting
in America this year clearly obviously
still some time to go as well gun
violence is steadily increasing in
America year on year and whatever
emerges from this event and I'm sure in
the coming hours and days we'll hear
more about the motive of the shooter
involved we do know that the shooter was
killed as well in this incident whatever
emerges we need to reflect or America
has to reflect once again on what is a
uniquely American problem this
astonishing level of gun violence and
perhaps the laws that maybe allow this
sort of thing to happen on such a
regular basis here yeah so just to recap
for us then if you would please Martha
multiple deaths were hearing at the
moment the gunman uh has also uh been
killed we haven't got exact numbers as
you said yet though
we haven't got exact numbers uh the
police officer who was delivering that
press conference was asked whether it
was more than 10 he said he didn't
believe there had been 10 fatalities but
he did say that they found multiple
people injured including
um someone who appears to have been
killed uh close to the entrance of that
store there's clearly a lot of
conjecture at the moment about the
motives of the gunman whether this was a
disgruntled employee perhaps a
disgruntled customer or whether this was
just simply a random event a random
store uh picked out but it's a couple of
days away from the Thanksgiving holidays
at the moment so clearly uh 10 10 p.m at
night is not a time when that shop would
be as busy as other periods during the
day but this is an incredibly busy
holiday period as they call it here just
two days away from the Thanksgiving
holiday so there will have been a fair
number of people you would imagine
inside that store even though it was
around 45 minutes from closing time and
so I I think we'll we'll hear more I
think from a press conference from the
Chesapeake Police Department in the
coming hours but clearly police still on
the scene there and as until very
recently they were still searching
around that very large Supermarket
looking for people who perhaps had been
trying to find a hiding place to escape
the violence that was unfolding inside
um okay for now thanks very much indeed
thanks a lot so we are waiting to hear
more information from the police in the
area but what we are hearing from
looking at those ladies pictures up to
10 people are dead after a shooting at a
Walmart let's have a look at those
pictures again should we
um let's have a look at those pictures
again should we a Walmart uh shooting up
to 10 people have been killed um we
believe that the gunman is
um also amongst the dead this is at
Chesapeake in Virginia on the east coast
of the United States this story
developing in the last half an hour or
so U.S police saying the gunman is uh
dead as several Shoppers inside that
store around about 10 o'clock at night
um also having lost their lives as a
result of this shooting we'll get more
information and as soon as we do of
course we'll bring it to you here on Sky
News
Manchester United's American owners have
confirmed they could sell the club it
comes after Sky News exclusively
revealed the Glazer family Was preparing
to announce the news and we're already
being advised by Bankers fans of
Manchester United have long campaigned
against the club's American owners who
they accuse of a lack of investment and
saddling the club with too much debt one
man definitely leaving is Cristiano
Ronaldo whose time at Old Trafford has
ended uh Mark kleiman reports
foreign
do we have Mark Clement's report
okay we've got Mark instead hi Mark good
morning to you tell us more about your
exclusive
morning Kate
yeah that's right okay I mean this is 17
years of controversy under the Glazer's
ownership of Manchester United which may
be finally coming to an end as you say a
period that's been marred by protests
and declining performance on the pitch
Manchester United have not won the
Premier League title for 10 years nearly
and a trophy list for the last five
years what's interesting about this
announcement last night in the wake of
my story is that it's the first time
that the glazes have openly acknowledged
that they would be prepared to seek
fresh investment into the club and
importantly in their statements to the
New York Stock Exchange late last night
the the board of the club confirmed that
they are open to an outright sale now
the attention is inevitably going to
turn uh K to who exactly might step up
with the multi-billion pound check that
would be required to end the Glazer's
ownership there's going to be a lot of
speculation in the cup in the coming in
the coming months and as I uh revealed
in this report last night the uh the
period of the Glazer's ownership uh will
be coming to an end will be welcomed by
fans uh from around the world
lucrative troubled and turbulent is the
Glazer family's tenure at Manchester
United nearing the final whistle almost
20 years after taking control of
arguably the world's most famous
football club The Old Trafford outfit
has confirmed an exclusive Sky news
report that its owners are exploring a
sale the glazes have been controversial
figures throughout their time at United
and the lack of a premier league title
since 2013 has only intensified fans
antipathy it is 17 years where the club
was Laden with a lot of debt which has
not been paid down the levels of debt
the same today as they were in 2005
and that's led to a lack of investment
both in the playing side and we see that
on the pitch but also in the stadium the
state of Old Trafford that used to be
you know one of our great sources of
Pride and it isn't anymore
[Applause]
United's involvement with the old-fated
European Super League provided one of
many flashpoints
[Music]
and it may be the failure of that
project which has finally persuaded the
owners to sell absolutely without
question uh the last 10 years of the
stewardship has been not far short of
disastrous it's the business model
they've established it is incorrect and
wrong they pay themselves dividends the
only Premier League club where directors
pay themselves dividends the time is
right to sell
the Glazer's depth fuel take over 17
years ago preceded a boom in the
valuations of England's top football
clubs
the American Family paid 790 million
pounds earlier this year Chelsea changed
hands for two and a half billion pounds
Liverpool is now reportedly up for sale
okay as I was saying they're in my
report there will be a lot of interest
in buying Manchester United but what's
interesting is that of course with
Liverpool also potentially for sale this
may be seen by many investors as
representing the high water mark for the
valuations of English Premier League
clubs particularly in the wake of the
failure of that European Super League
project a couple of years ago now it's
important to note that any new owner
would come in that would need the
blessing of the fans there is a new fan
share ownership scheme being put
together at Old Trafford at the moment
and even former players were wading into
the debate last night
I think the fireworks will be going off
I think there'll be a party I think
everybody'll be absolutely delighted
that that this is going to go ahead if
it goes ahead I mean it's uh it looks
certainly a very serious option for them
now so let's keep our fingers crossed
and uh let's make the fans happy and
let's let's rebuild the uh the club as
well as the team
okay this isn't going to be a quick sell
process so I would expect it to take
several months it's going to be a very
very fraught process but I would think
that uh by the end of this current
season we will see new owners in place
at Manchester United
okay thank you
uh the Supreme Court will rule today on
whether the Scottish Parliament has the
power to call for a second Independence
referendum without the approval of
Westminster
there are multiple possible outcomes of
today's ruling if the Scottish
government wins first Minister Nicholas
sturgeon will likely table the draft
referendum bill at the Scottish
Parliament where it would likely pass
because of the deal between the SMP and
the Scottish greens if the court sides
with the UK government consent is needed
from Westminster to rerun a referendum
another possible outcome is the court
deciding it's unable to rule on a holly
rude created referendum because the
planned legislation is still in draft
form or the court could decide to answer
the question while also accepting that
the Lord Advocate who's the senior
Scottish law officer did not have the
powers to refer the draft Bill to the
court in the first place well our
Scotland correspondent Connor is been in
five to find out how voters feel about
the prospect of a fresh poll
Fife voted no to Independence eight
years ago but has this place changed its
tune as the deadlock on Scotland's
future intensifies
pondering that over a pub lunch friends
Jim and Paul well in 2014 a vote no but
the way the country's gone I feel would
probably be better
going our own way I think the best way
forward is to get independence and then
we can vote for the party we want once
we've got that do you regret voting no
in 2014
um yes I do if there was to be a vote
tomorrow what way do you think it would
go the novel would win we're better
together and I want the world to get
smaller not bigger unlike in 2014 when
there was agreement from both sides
prime ministers in recent years have
said politicians in this place Hollywood
cannot legally hold another referendum
as the powers to do so are reserved to
Westminster something judges at the
Supreme Court are set to rule on there
are various ways this could go the
Scottish government could win and
activists say that would essentially
fire the starting gun on the campaign
for a referendum in October next year
the Scottish government will be able to
table its independence referendum bill
and it's likely to get the green light
because the majority of msps are
independent supporting the other
alternative is that the UK government's
argument wins that hollerud cannot
legislate for an independence referendum
Nicola sturgeon says in that scenario
she would use the next general election
as a de facto referendum
well there is this point that the first
Minister has said that the 2024 UK
general election be a de facto
referendum on Independence and by
implication where her party or her party
and its nationalist allies to get more
than 50 of the vote they would see that
as a mandate to seek Independence
negotiations but again that's simply
first of all if that's a very high
hurdle uh secondly
um that's a political debating Point
rather than anything of standing in in
uh in in law the stage is set once again
for this latest Crescendo in a
constitutional conversation which has
Scotland split straight down the middle
Conor Gillis Sky News
Joe's at the Supreme Court for us this
morning hi Joe four possible options
that they can return
[Music]
yeah and there is a debate over whether
there could even be more than that okay
depends really on on who you ask and
neither side has any early indication or
early sight of that judgment they'll
find out the UK government Scottish
government as we all will at 9 45 today
this is really one of those Crossroads
moments which could determine the future
constitutional direction of the UK
certainly what the UK government seemed
reasonably confident in is that this uh
attempt by the Scottish government will
fail in some way quite quite sort of
details of the ruling is of course
unclear but they think our confident
that they can win and there are senior
figures I've spoken to within the
Scottish government who concede the
weight of legal opinion is probably
against them that doesn't mean though
even if the Scottish government lose in
some way they can't use this to build
support further for a Scottish
independence Lord Reid who's the
president of the Supreme Court will be
delivering that judge and at 9 45 it
should last between 10 to 15 minutes and
then the rest of the day I'm sure we'll
have a responses from the UK and
Scottish government certainly Rishi
sunak is prepped to respond at pmqs at
12.
very much indeed and we'll bring you the
Supreme Court ruling live here on Sky
News as Joe was saying around about 9 45
this morning as Joe was saying likely to
last between 10 and 15 minutes could
there be another referendum in Scotland
stay tuned and find out
meantime there are concerns surrounding
Harry Kane at the world cup with the
England captains set to have a scan on
his right ankle ahead of Friday's match
against the United States uh let's get
more should we Ali standing by for us in
Doha this morning
um everybody here in the UK hold it well
certainly in England holding their
breath what's the latest Alistar
I bet they are they are fans here too
Harry can we understand this again to go
and have a scan uh on his ankle he
limped off it seems as though he was
injured pretty early on in the first
heart in the second half when England
played Iran here on Monday
the mood music coming out of the England
Camp might suggest that this is slightly
precautionary uh we'll wait and see what
happens at the press conference later on
this afternoon we'll have a team there
so we'll get an update on it but of
course uh Harry Kane not just England's
Captain but a leading goal scorer as
well and so everyone will be keeping
their fingers crossed that his ankle is
okay uh he's not the only injury worry
James Madison hasn't been training
really at all since England arrived here
in Qatar he's another inform forward as
well uh Callum Wilson and Harry MaGuire
who both played a part in England's
victory over Iran both have sort of
small niggling injury worries but I
don't think anything too much to be
concerned about so really the focus is
on Harry Kane is on the England Captain
and the hope that when that scans uh and
is done and the results come back it's
not too serious
okay thank you looking at some of
today's other headlines for you now and
the rmt has announced a fresh wave of
rail strikes over the festive period
around 40 000 staff from Network Rail
and 14 train companies are set to strike
on the 30th 14th 16th and 17th of
December and the 4th 6th and 7th of
January
parliamentary Watchdog has ruled that
Matt Hancock broke government rules by
not seeking permission before appearing
on I'm a celebrity get me out of here
the former Health secretary who has
already been stripped of the Tory whip
for his reality TV appearance failed to
consult the advisory committee on
business appointments before joining the
program
I just stop oil activists who glued
herself to a van Gogh painting has told
a court the artist may have agreed with
the demonstration and went on to compare
the actions to Martin Luther King
activist Louis McKenzie and Emily
brockleban were found guilty of causing
just under 2 000 pounds worth of
criminal damage to the frame of the
artwork
has covid-19 cases rise in China the
country's Zero Tolerance strategy stands
firm with Beijing introducing new
restrictions to curb infections here
people will have to provide proof of a
negative test 48 hours before entering
public areas like restaurants Office
Buildings and shopping centers this
comes after the ruling Communist Party
promised to make controls more flexible
to appease an increasingly Restless
population
foreign
let's just update you on the latest on a
shooting at a wall Mark in Chesapeake in
Virginia which is on the U.S east Coast
um police are saying up to 10 people
have been killed including the gunman uh
reports of a shooting at 10 15 local
time 10 15 p.m
um we're told that
multiple dead people reports from
officers on the ground injured as well
in the store and rescue and tactical
teams have been put together to go
inside and provide life-saving measures
police believe there was one gunman who
is dead as I said they believe that the
shooting had stopped when the police
arrived
and long story short of the course of
the next 30 45 minutes we were able to
find multiple fatalities and multiple
injured parties with the Chesapeake fire
department we were able to put rescue
and tactical teams together to go inside
to
um
provide life-saving measures rapidly and
quickly and then uh through the course
of the investigation we believe was a
single shooter and we believe that
shooter is deceased at this time
I will get more on that and update you
as soon as we can but the latest we are
hearing is that several people are dead
including a gunman after a shooting a
late night shooting at a Walmart in
Chesapeake in Virginia on the east coast
of the United States
well as the Supreme Court prepares to
rule on whether the Scottish Parliament
can hold an independence referendum
without westminster's approval speaking
to the former first Minister that's
Henry mcleish
Labor's Shadow Chief secretary to the
treasury Pat McFadden will be with us
soon after eight o'clock
and following the announcement of a
fresh wave of rail strikes over the busy
Christmas period Speaking to the boss of
the rmt Union that's Mick Lynch
before I was out now let's bring in the
work and pensions secretary who's with
us this morning hi um you want to tell
us about 600 Quid that's being given to
pensioners is how much of a dent is that
going to make on their household energy
bills well it comes within a broader
package of support for the most
vulnerable and I think this has been a
core mission of this government has to
make sure we support people as best we
can if they are vulnerable or less
well-off so there's 650 pounds so it's
gone to a million low-income households
300 pounds going out with the winter
fuel payment so it's up to 600 pounds
for millions of pensioners a million
pensioners today will actually receive
that amount 150 pounds if you're
disabled 400 pounds off uh energy uh
bills and of course the energy price
guarantee which means that people are
saving on on average 900 pounds this
year on their energy costs so a huge
package of which pensions are a very
important part of it and bear in mind
Kay in the Autumn statement the
chancellor announced that the triple
lock will be honored going forward and
we've also up rated pensions by CPI by
10.1 and yet civil sermons so we're
hearing this morning still have to use
food banks
so clearly anybody in a position where
they need to use a food bank is not
right and is something that through time
one would hope that we will get to a
point where nobody needs to use a Food
Bank what the government recognizes is
that as with other countries around the
world we've been really hit very hard by
first the pandemic and then of course by
the war between Ukraine and Russia and
the impact that that's had not just on
energy actually even on foodstuffs and
other products as well which is created
a lot of inflation so given that
backdrop we can't do everything but we
are doing the absolute maximum that we
can whilst getting inflation down and
getting the economy righted so we can
get growth and prosperity moving into
the future and yet people go to the
doctor they're poorly they should be
signed off sick they won't take a sick
note because they have to go to work
otherwise they won't get paid and our
prime minister is spending 250 quid to
be able to see a private GP at the drop
of a hat you understand stand the
disparity there well I think as regards
the the prime minister's personal
medical Arrangements I I do think
they're a matter for the Prime Minister
but as I say what the government is
absolutely intent on doing and is doing
is making sure that wherever we can we
are helping the most vulnerable in
society so outside of those direct
payments and I've mentioned we've also
just put up the national living wage by
almost 10 percent the highest increase
in the history of the national living
wage we've already previously made
adjustments for example to the Universal
Credit uh taper so that people keep more
of the money as they move from uh
Universal Credit into work we are
providing all sorts of supports at all
sorts of levels but very much aimed at
just the people you're referring to
those who need the help the most so you
don't think it's any of our business
that the Prime Minister can jump a queue
if he needs to go and see the doctor
whereas other people have to wait to
Fortnight well to say I I think people's
personal medical arrangements are things
that if they choose to make public
that's fine but I think it's a campaign
based on the NHS wasn't it well and
we're totally dedicated to that judge
him by his actions and the health
secretary's actions on the NHS
in that very difficult
very difficult Autumn statement which
had a lot of very hard choices that had
to be made two things really stood out
one was an increased commitment to
funding education but the other was the
Health Service and social care which
actually got quite a lot of money in the
near term so the commitment that we have
to the NHS is absolutely Central uh to
this government and that is something
that's very much driven from the top by
the prime okay so it's none of our
business you're saying whether the prime
minister is Private health care well I'm
just saying I think we should respect
people's okay let me ask you the fact
that they should be able to let me keep
trying do you think that people who can
afford it should pay to see a GP
privately so that other people don't
have to wait a fortnight I don't think
that we should have a situation
regarding the NHS that in any way
interferes with the fundamental concept
of the NHS which is based on need not
ability to pay
if people can afford to pay though
giffen the situation that we found
ourselves in the moment should they take
the lead of the Prime Minister and go
privately
people's decisions on that are for
people to make individually but as I say
I think the the principle here is that
Arrangements like that are quite rightly
private to those individuals that choose
to take those decisions I don't think
they people should have to publicly
declare exactly what their medical is if
they're a public servant yeah I do I
think that there's a principle here I
mean I understand the sort of line of
questioning that you're pursuing but I
think it's what do you think people are
thinking at home this morning when
they've rung the doctors and being told
their child is unwell but they have to
wait for a fortnight to sit and then the
guy who's representing them who wants
their vote at the next election can pay
250 quid and and hop in his
chauffeur-driven car and go to the
doctors well what I I'm saying very
clearly is that when it comes to the NHS
that is an absolute number one priority
for the government judge the Prime
Minister judge the government by our
actions on that in the recent Autumn
statement huge tough choices had to be
made both on spending and on taxation
but the one area that got extra support
really serious eight billion pounds
worth of extra support for social care
for example was the National Health
Service so we are absolutely clear on
this we are totally connected to our NHS
we are totally committed to it being
free at the point of use and that it's
available for everybody on an equal
basis with no queue jumping or anything
like that money will not buy you
preferential treatments on the NHS it
can be there free at the point of view
yeah based on need what we're going to
do about the rail strikes so I think
what's regrettable is that the trade
unions have come forward with a series
of dates and Strikes now are clearly
aimed at causing maximum uh disruption
across the that's what prescribed Before
Christmas period but before you reach
the point of strikes you should really
exhaust all the other avenues because
strikes are very serious they impact not
just general Journeys but sometimes
people to get back to the medical points
that you're raising who actually need
that transport to get to important
medical appointments for example so what
we need is more engagement and
discussion between those businesses that
are running the railways and network
Rail and the trade unions in order to
come to a balanced realistic outcome and
what I mean by that is it has to be fair
to taxpayers who are funding the
railways and put a lot of money into
their airways during the pandemic not
least to support the jobs of those
working within those Railways but it has
to also be fair to passengers when it
comes to the fairs that they're expected
pay and it has to work with the public
finances but I think the unions need to
engage further on this and we need to
not rush into these strikes
at a time that's really designed to
cause maximum discomfort to the public
what are you going to do about the
transport services Bill why don't you
bring that forward I'm sure you could
get it through the house very quickly if
you decided to as a result there would
be a minimum service that would be
provided yes why is that taking so long
maybe you're so legislation takes it a
little while I think sometimes I I say
this as a former leader of the house I
used to be responsible for managing
registration yes indeed and the
government has a commitment in that area
and to minimum Service uh provision and
in due course I've no doubt that that
will will come forward and I do think
it's important because I think we
shouldn't be left in position in certain
services such as Railways where we have
such an acute dependence upon them for a
variety of reasons there's no plans
where the whole thing can just be the
plug can be pulled on the whole thing
there's no plan to bring It Forward I
mean well there were in due course as I
say it is something that the government
will be will be looking at then talk to
me about a lot of including former work
and pension secretary Chloe Smith I'm
looking at William ragg and both quite
young MPS and yet they're sent saying
that they're not going to stand at the
next election for your party what's
going on well at every uh general
election there are a number of people
who who step aside uh I think in Chloe's
case I think it's for family reasons she
has young children and she's taken that
decision and I totally respect that I
think what has triggered it in the
immediate term is that the part that the
party has required to basically take a
decision within the next couple of weeks
as to whether they stand or not so I
think you're going to see a lot of those
decisions crystallizing in a very short
period of time a lot of MPS do tend to
step down something like five percent of
the house will step down during a
re-election but not youngsters like
these two well I I I don't think with
with respect to Chloe and others they're
the only younger people that have
decided not to fight a a forthcoming uh
election but I think the most important
thing um add any weight to your argument
well my argument is that people stand
down and uh some of those will be
younger and some of those will be older
and you've cited two examples of uh
relatively uh younger people but the
important things exactly compared to me
I went to the department at age 47. well
there we go so that was the way I did it
um and talk to me about what's going on
with this housing Rebellion there was
supposed to be a vote on getting 300 000
houses built uh a year and quite a few
of your colleagues are saying we don't
agree with that for all sorts of reasons
your boss is worried about losing the
version so he's kicked it into long
grass okay well I I don't know that any
announcement has been made about
rescheduling of legislation the leader
of the house will come to the house
tomorrow as part of their business day
so it may still go ahead and tell us
more about that yeah the answer is I
don't know we'll have to wait and see
until the leader of the House comes
forward tomorrow so what I'm reading in
the papers is wrong on that in that well
the papers are sometimes right okay and
some sometimes they are wrong we'll get
the answer to that essay question
tomorrow it's like a sieve
um will you use taxpayers money to have
a Christmas party this year definitely
not definitely not okay I'm and I think
what would you say to other MPS who are
thinking of doing well I I it's for them
to decide but look let's be clear about
what's happened here okay the the
general view I think out there is the
MPS have somehow designed things so that
they're able to charge the taxpayer for
Christmas parties and decorations and
drinks and things like that that could
not be further from the truth ipsa which
is an independent body has taken that
decision it certainly wasn't it yeah
um yeah yes so it then becomes a case of
then do individual energy so what would
you say to individually well my decision
I I try to avoid lecturing other MPS as
to what they should do I mean there's
certain circumstances I certainly would
do that but I think on this yeah
everybody has to take their own judgment
my firm view is that in my case I will
not not be doing that I don't think it
sends the right signal I don't actually
think that it's as decision is the right
one and I know that a number of my
colleagues share that view and are quite
what's the word quite upset about the
fact actually that ipsa has put all
enemies in a position where the public
is saying well you're all up to spending
our hard-earned money on your Christmas
celebrations and that's not right I
suspect the vast majority of MPS would
agree with that but we've been put in
that position
what decision will have you celebrating
um at the Supreme Court today what do
you want to hear well I I think what we
want to hear is is just the results of
their conclusions which will be at 9 45
this morning I don't think it'd be right
for me to stop pre-judging that or
saying well if it's this I think this or
if it's that I think something
differently I think we have to wait to
see what they come forward really
I do I think well it's a big moment
um there's been you know the government
put its case I think last month um uh
with with Vigor other case your other
arguments have been put forward we now
need to give the judges just a little
bit of extra space to come forward later
this morning and then let's let's talk
about what this is okay what do you
think of the football
this is the sale of Ronaldo is it
Manchester United Manchester United yeah
well I I think at the end of England
would you prefer well I I think these
are commercial decisions
um I don't personally think it's for
government to weigh in on too
frequencies so you're pretty reluctant
the Saudis buy it
um well it I you know as I said
something else this morning yeah when I
just don't I don't think that you know
we're always urged as governments sort
of get involved in all sorts of areas of
of sports and and I think that's just
one which I I might resist okay but you
did watch the England yeah I did and I
thought we were terrific and it was a
great result and uh you know Harry Kane
needs to see it has crossed sorry
hurricane needs a scan on his ankle
right well that's that's not that's a
fly in the ointments
but who knows you know I've just got a
good feeling about England this time and
Wales of course too who did very well
okay it's great to see you as always
thanks very much thank you
uh let's talk about Indie ref actually
in a bit more detail should we the
former first minister of Scotland Henry
mcleish is with us now hello to you
thanks for joining us on the program
this morning
um the minister wouldn't be drawn on
what he wanted to hear from the Supreme
Court today what about you
well I think he um you certainly did
have an exhausting number of questions
to answer but but look this is important
but I believe that we've reached a point
in the history of the evolution where
we've got to step back clearly the
Supreme Court is looking at the question
of could Scotland move forward have its
independence rate for everyone but I
would rather concentrate on whether
Scotland should actually have a
referendum I suspect that there's three
possible outcomes one is that Scotland
has the power to proceed with the
legislation secondly and it is reserved
to Westminster as per the Scotland act
1998 or thirdly the court may decide
that this is all very premature and they
will wait until the actual legislation
goes through these the Scottish
Parliament so that is one side of it
that's the legal side but I think the
politics of it is much more complex my
belief is that we shouldn't be having a
referendum now next year or even within
the next five years there are so many
important issues to be dealing with and
sadly the SNP have exhausted the
political energy in relation to
Independence that they're not applying
themselves to the kind of big issues
that are facing not only the United
Kingdom but to Scotland and my main
thesis is that we need to give
Devolution a chance to work that would
be looking at the Long View not the
short term and I think that the point
has to be made key that in 1707 we had a
manufactured Union in 1997 we started on
the Devolution Road this is 2022 and I
believe there's much more potential in
the Scottish Parliament to be realized
before we think of moving on you were
very much involved I think I'm right in
saying in Tony Blair's government in
order to set up Devolution or to enable
Devolution in the first place
um is Devolution working so far as you
would have hoped
no it's not key and I think that really
is the source of my concern I mean we
have 25 years now of the Scottish
Parliament it's done some remarkable
work but it's not realizing its
potential that's partly because since
since 19 since 2007 really we've had a
campaign for Independence but we've had
really no debate on where Scotland is
actually moving and if you look at the
current situation like the UK we're
experiencing multiple crises Scottish
public opinion is bitterly divided there
is no settled will of course we have a
situation where the um momentum for
Independence has has disappeared and of
course we have a situation which worries
me that Scotland is stalled we're not
applying ourselves to the real issues
that we're facing and that's why I
believe we come back to the evolution
we've had 25 years it seems a long time
but in the history of the UK Union it's
a short period I would like to think we
concentrate on some of the bigger issues
we concentrate on some of the policy
issues that I think are being neglected
and as far as I'm concerned the mood the
mind of Scots are not are not on this
question of having a referendum look
nobody has a crystal ball it may well be
the case in 20 25 years time maybe
earlier that Scots will decide they want
Divo Max they want home rule they want
more Devolution they want more
Independence
but my judgment is this is not the time
to be taking these big political and
constitutional decisions it's a time for
making the evolution work and for the
independence campaign to be sidelined so
that Scots can concentrate on the matter
on issues that matter to Scots yeah but
that's a democracy for you Mr mcleish
isn't it you're not in power anymore at
the SMP very much is and they want a
referendum they say that's what the
Scottish people want
well I'm not sure that's the that
clearly comes from the the points you've
made key because look we have a
situation where the country's divided
down the middle 50 50 to be generous it
could be 60 40 in favor of staying in
the union look I think the union is
partly the Catalyst for all this unrest
if you look at the contempt the the look
at Ireland the contempt with which
they're looking at the Irish protocol
with Northern Ireland where was the
treat with contempt we have a situation
in England where there's restlessness
and some of the metropolitan areas and
of course under Johnson with this idea
of brittle unionism so part of my vision
is to see that Scotland concentrates now
on the issues that matter but
westminster's got to take a think to
itself it can't continue the way it's
going because it's centralized governing
of the United Kingdom it's perilous for
the four nations that make it up but I
think also clear we've got to realize
that when we talk about democracy
um very few Scots are actually in favor
of our second Independence referendum
known
we have a situation where the country is
divided and of course there's the famous
Abraham Lincoln comment that you know A
House Divided cannot stand so we've got
much to do in Scotland which has nothing
to do with Independence but what we have
got to do is to deal with some of these
important issues you're right I'm not in
power I'm not in politics but I do think
that after looking at the issue for 25
years being on the floor of the house
taking the legislation through
Devolution has got to work better the
parliament has huge potential and it's
important that not only the union
um sees itself not fit for purpose but
the Scottish traditional part is
liberals labor conservatives actually
now apply more enthusiasm to the
Scottish Parliament and build a way
forward let's Nation build
let's institutional reform let's do a
number of things that will make Scotland
better that will give us a chance in the
long term to say okay is there a next
step for Scotland and at that point some
action may be taken but clearly this is
not the right time now to move forward
in the way that the s p want to do it's
great to talk to you again thanks so
much for taking the time this morning
thank you thank you for the opportunity
tomorrow is with us to reflect on what
we've heard from the government Minister
this morning talking is about the next
tranche of money that's being given to
pensioners but not wanting to talk about
a Rishi sunax private medicine
that's right uh this story that appeared
in the guardian about which you've seen
using a private uh GP and there's a
question for politicians about whether
they use the same Services as the rest
of us whether it's the NHS or state
schools I remember David Cameron made a
great play of sending his children to
State schools indeed and um and whether
that makes them in touch with the rest
of us and of course conservative
ministers are lining up to say what
matters is what he's doing for the NHS
and in the Autumn statement there was a
surprise
um bung of money to the NHS 6.6 billion
pounds over two years which NHS leaders
say is not enough but it's something
there was also money for schools in
there so they say judge him on his
record but of course the difficulty is
that many public services are facing a
very difficult time over the next few
months and of course you didn't say
people should you go private if they can
in order to take the pressure off
because that is not that's not the
official message no and also when we
talked about strikes there's no plan to
bring forward the bill to stop unions
striking to the except
um to the extent that they are not so
the bill that would ensure a minimum
service on the railways is going through
Parliament it's it started it's making
progress these things take a while but
um even during these strikes that um
Nick Lynch of the rmt has announced
eight days of strikes over Christmas not
the present anyone wanted
um they are going to be having some
trains running I think it's about one in
five trains will be running on those
days but of course masses of disruption
for people visiting family or going to
events that they've they've booked over
the festive period can the government
agree something I mean there are reports
in the papers today unconfirmed that the
rmt have been offered an eight percent
rise over two years but it isn't just
about pay it's also about jobs and
conditions and whether they can keep
hold of all of those uh jobs
um doing what has you know been a
massively financially damaging period
for the railways okay thanks very much
Anita tomorrow's take of course at nine
o'clock this morning quick look at the
papers for you lots of them are picking
up on the announcement of a fresh wave
of strike speaking to Mick Lynch or as
you can see the way the Metro are
describing him as Mick Grinch we'll have
another look through the papers a bit
later on but do want to bring in
um Serena who is a sixth form student
and she is 18. hello to you it's nice to
see you look great this morning thanks
for coming in
um talk to me about mental health
challenges because that's the the topic
that we want to talk about young people
struggling during the pandemic tell me
about your story so
um I struggled with a social anxiety
following the pandemic
because everybody was at home during
quarantine and we were stuck seeing the
same people constantly my routine became
repetitive I became comfortable with
that but once a quarantine was over and
I had to go talk to strangers and get
back to regular life I felt really
stressed being put in those type of
situations and it really affected my
mental health so what have you done
about it
um I reached out online to like help so
I did a bit of research about social
anxiety I read some books I talked to
friends I talked to teachers and they
really walked me through it and I've
gotten much better okay so what would
your advice be to young people getting
ready for school this morning who might
find themselves in the same position as
you
um talk to friends talk to teachers
people are here to help you shouldn't be
scared to reach out everybody wants the
best for you so Reach Out reach out to
anybody who's willing to listen do you
have any top tips that you can share
with us
um when it comes to dealing with you
know stressful situations
um
people are not don't care enough to
judge you so don't worry too much about
people's opinions like people have their
own insecurities their own stresses so
their their opinions of you won't affect
you so you should just go on with life
and not let their your insecurities
affect your life and are there any
physical things that you do sort of to
walk into a room that you're anxious
about because you know you've been used
to just being on your own and now you're
having to go in and talk to people on
television and then I um take a few deep
breaths really Center yourself and just
go in head first yeah I think that's
very good advice I find that if I Pat my
chest like this and then it reminds
apparently it's supposed to remind you
of when you were in the womb and it's
sort of like the heartbeat of when you
were in the womb so that I find that
really helps I don't know if you want to
try that at some stage in the future you
don't have to do it right now
um how you're getting on with your A
Levels um it's going quite good yeah
what do you study
um biology philosophy and ethics and
psychology oh fantastic and what do you
want to do when
um you leave University are you going to
University yeah because you don't have
to but
um I hope to do become a solicitor
hello oh you're going to be properly
clever aren't you fantastic and you're
you feel completely happy now and you
can deal with any
um situational scenario um I want to say
completely but I'm getting there okay
and there are there are opportunities
online for people if they want to reach
out but I'm guessing you just need to be
quite careful about some social media
sites you don't want to be going down
that rabbit holding yeah you need to be
quite careful about where you reach out
so you just need to make sure you do
your research and you're safe online
Okay
um going to school now yeah good what's
your first lesson
um philosophy and ethics oh okay
excellent excellent have a great day and
enjoy the Christmas period and um keep
doing what you're doing it's great to
see you look forward to interviewing you
when you're a lawyer go with me just one
second if you would because someone will
come and help you out of the studio
thank you
uh let's take you to Ukraine now where
people have been promised shelters will
be created with heat and water to
encourage citizens to conserve energy
with a harsh winter looming amid
continuing Russian airstrikes joining us
now is the Ukrainian MP Kira Riddick um
hi Kira it's good to see you again
thanks for joining us on the program uh
this morning how is the situation
amongst your fellow citizens this
morning
hello okay thank you so much for having
me
um while the winter is here uh the snow
is on the ground in Kiev and of course
people are worried on how they're going
to go through the winter people are
saving on electricity buying generators
buying different kinds of heaters and
getting ready to the energy outages so
basically we're having them every single
day but in different parts of the city
and different parts of the country on
different times
it's a very good idea to have the
shelters and to have the stations for uh
for people to charge their phones to
come and just get some worms and have a
cup of tea and have a little break in
their day when they are when they have
to be outside and have and feel the
support of each other because the main
thing that we feel right now is that we
can only go through this winter together
that we will need to take care not only
of ourselves but of the people around us
and that the responsibility is to get
every single Ukrainian through the
winter
yeah but there is huge concern about
energy Supply and that affects heating
lighting water as well and so these um
bunkers if you will I suppose are being
set up for Ukrainian citizens to go and
spend some time I suppose that's taking
them back to the early days of the war
again what impact is that going to have
on morale
um surprisingly morale right now is very
high so people are taking the upcoming
winter as a challenge a complicated
challenge but not as a tragedy so we
anticipated that there would be another
flow of refugees to the neighboring
countries like Poland but right now we
do not see this happening we see that
people are staying at home and people
are getting ready to go through the
winter at home I can tell you right now
uh people are supporting each other in a
tremendous way helping the cities to set
up those shelters and helping to prepare
to the winter not only themselves but
they are neighbors but elderly people
who cannot support themselves taking on
more and more responsibility to
um basically to stay alive to go through
the winter and to make sure that we will
be capable of fighting and spring as
well
and just talk to me about something that
the European Parliament is up to
um they're calling uh to recognize
Wagner group as a terrorist organization
it's um as we know private you know
certainly a private mercenary militia
led by one of Putin's allies what's your
view on that
of course it will be a good step to make
uh because they are terrorist
organization if they will be recognized
by European Parliament it will stop this
organization from working in different
African countries and will limit their
influence because this influence is
growing these are basically trained
military who are fighting for the ones
who are paying them and they are
supporting many conflicts throughout the
world so it is necessary to to stop them
and to limit their growth right now
however what we are expecting more is
for European Parliament to vote for
acknowledging Russia State sponsor of
terrorism because it will enact uh
additional sets of sanctions from
different National parliaments and also
it will allow us to faster seize Russian
assets and use them for the sake of
Ukraine I think it's completely unfair
that the burden on supporting of Ukraine
is going on to people who are actually
supporting us I think Putin needs to pay
for his own crimes there is enough money
stored everywhere in the world to cover
for the support that we are receiving
it's about 500 billion dollars right now
and we need to use this money uh and we
need to use them as soon as possible
until putting like pulls them and uh or
oligarchs will start suing to get them
back so this is one of the important
cases that we are working on to get the
support for the country okay and thanks
very much Lee for joining us as always
live from Kiev thank you
did a great look at the weather for you
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weapon sponsored by Qatar Airways
okay this is what it's looking like
today lots of rain as you can see are
continuing to move uh eastwards uh
across the country
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
planning to head overseas which has
found that Leeds Bradford Airport is the
worst in the country for security cues
passengers wait for an average of 35
minutes while a quarter of passengers
said they waited for more than an hour
Bristol is ranked second worst while
London City Airport was crowned the best
with waiting times of just 12 minutes
now I think there's probably a reason
for that they don't have many passengers
do they but who am I to say let us know
your thoughts do you have an airport
that you think is good or bad at airport
queues